don't you miss Apple looks cute and ripe
and young just kidding this Apple is old
as hell due to a little something called
controlled atmosphere storage Apple's
can take a long time to ripen which
means this baby Apple could actually be
over a year old
here's the thing about cherries
sometimes after a heavy rain little
cherries can split open so cherry
farmers will send big old helicopters to
fly over their crop to air dry them so
they don't freak out and break apart
talk about like [ __ ] divas am i right
fun little fact about oranges they're
not always orange sometimes they're
green in places where it's hot
all the time oranges will stay green
because they only turned orange after
the weather gets cool might be safe to
assume that strawberries are fairies
right wrong strawberries are actually
something called accessory fruits which
means they were developed in areas
outside of the fruits ovaries I don't
even know fruits have ovaries watch out
grapefruits can interact with certain
medications in ways that can be really
harmful to your body it's so scary but
it's so cute do you love bananas because
I love bananas
but sadly they might be extinct in if
you care due to a little ZZZ called
tropical race 4 I could go for a nice
salad with handsome banan what's up baby
how you doing